[Applaudissements]
bien irradiées au plateau de sa lumière
divine
votre guide cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
alors malheureusement je n'ai pas vu la
danse de daniel mais là les deux
maintenant que je vous vois ensemble
c'est là et ben je me dit elle c'est
vrai ce tango il était peut-être pas
innocent annoncé quand je dis quelque
chose
franchement il s'est prolongé mondiale
vit le tango grand-père grand-mère
caisse car il pourra voir grand père de
gros merde ça va très bien en tout cas
vous êtes très beau c'est gentil merci
vous aussi comme tout le monde à la vue
qui baisse alors mais qui affaiblit la
fédé uv lui aujourd'hui
non mais sans rire il est bronzé on
dirait qu'il revient de fait des heures
de sport ce matin mais raoui ouais mec a
vraiment rien à [ __ ] quand on fait
deux heures de sport on écrire ou bronze
pas les moyens parce que je rougis
ah ouais l'effort qui est fait beau s'y
mettre mais vous êtes rouge depuis ce
matin
[Applaudissements]
alors ça s'annonce bien
qu'est-ce qu'il est beau ce tapis de sol
il est magnifique je devais le projet
magnifique bravoure une bouteille de
parfum c'est magnifique mais ça va et
alors vous feignez oui vous avez des
eaux cde vx leader dans les environs
alors ce que voulait passer aux
questions enquêteurs j'adore votre
équipe sur duke faudra rendre le rideau
de douche à quoi expliquer ce qui se
passe on a des missions de fin de
semaine donc tout ce qui n'est pas tout
ce qui n'a pas été coulée le reste de la
semaine ça passe chez nous au niveau
fringues ah oui mais c'est sûr que c'est
vrai toi tu es très beau ainsi comme
vous touchez un peu mais volontiers que
c'est un bonheur si je suis excité fait
attendre est ce que voulait une question
bien dormi choc allez on y va
parti bonjour je m'appelle bernadette
j'ai été recalé les auditions de
n'oubliez pas les paroles
donc je voulais savoir est ce que je
pourrais venir dans votre émission car
vous avez l'air quand même moins
regardants merci davance aller
on est en plein dans quelque chose comme
ça et je comprends donc cette question
bernadette mais je crois qu'il grosse
méprise la semaine dernière ce n'était
pas des candidats de n'oubliez pas les
paroles sur le plateau mais une chorale
qui étaient venus rendre hommage à
charles aznavour annonce avoir répété
toute la journée
il n'aurait pas dû d'ailleurs on les
adore ils viennent régulièrement nous
voulons c'est toi mais tu sens que dans
leur répertoire gospel as d'amour c'est
parce qu'ils pratiquent tous les jours
là à mon avis on leur envoyait un bus
dans l'après midi ils sont monté dedans
et après sony au fait qu'est-ce qu'on
chante ce soir mais ça va franchement ça
s'est pas trop vu
je vous racontais si je suis un vieux
de là
retirée
[Musique]
femmes et l'amour
ap après j'ai voulu expliquer ce qui
s'est réellement passé ça parce qu'elle
s'était jeanine fin de phrase c'est à
dire là le début le milieu n'a pas du
tout balancer trois derniers mots pour
faire illusion collective juste sur elle
avant avant l'émission je vois les
répète et je vais l'avoir fait j'ai
voulu répéter sûr que si on est
tranquille c'est pour le répète mais tu
vas voir ce soir bible elle est très
sympathique et en plus le lapin dans les
phares je sens c'est que des fans
tracent encore plus flagrant vous allez
voir un peu plus loin dans la chanson
[Musique]
sur des monnaies
mais
[Musique]
j'étais fâché il était fâché mais il le
compteur suivaient pas ce tgv jeanine
fin de phrase et kad et olivier gouez
aussi prêté jean-michel invente des
paroles alors lui se démonte pas il n'a
pas les bons mots quand même quitte à
faire des phrases qui veulent rien dire
mais ça va aller sans c'est ce jour là
si c'est pas c'était qu'on ait de
l'émotion
oui la meilleure que s'il y en a eu
[Musique]
la télé
pas gardé le coeur libéré en chantant de
pau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que je suis vous dire ce qui s'est
passé c'est que il devait venir pour
autre chose complètement jean-luc
vraiment je me suis l'après midi on leur
a dit forcément est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire un petit hommage à charles de
meaux ils ont dit d'accord et c'est vrai
qu'en monnaies mois elle et ses ex
amants du rien et charles aznavour
voilà et franchement et les [ __ ] ses
rêves
je vous suis mais il y en aura c'est ont
été arrêtés ils viennent souvent nous
voir c'est là la première fois justement
qu'on a raison mais on rigole avec eux
voulaient joue pas en avance avec eux et
à l'hommage qui a été rendu aux
invalides piété qui était magnifique et
bien même la chorale qui a chanté
emmenez moi eh ben ils se sont trompés
dans les paroles non je vous jure que
c'est vrai si si alors l'été 2004 hier
on était juste sur la chorale qui
ramenait hommage à ce d'amour et
justement où mathieu était très énervé
je peux vous expliquer pourquoi
bien sûr parce que en fait savoir que
mathieu c'est un spécialiste de charles
aznavour et quelque part si tu veux
arrêter quand même il est capable de
chanter toutes les chansons les sur une
phrase je connaissais pas ça ça
s'appelle les micros hommage
je veux tout
[Musique]
66 ans karine
je vais
[Musique]
tibet delamuraz
je venais
qui sait
[Musique]
me benoit
les remarques sur la chorale arrêter la
voiture est d'abord l'occasion
john n'est pas formidable
merci on est toujours dans la fureur et
chanter avec nous elle refait nos
limitations rallye de france assure une
phrase qui respire croyons l'amitié
alors également une révélation très
étonnante sur un zoo du chanteur disparu
alors je dis tout de suite pour les
sites qui se précipitent à relier
n'importe quelle information pour faire
du clic ne quitterait pas matthieu
delormeau révéler ce qu'aurait voulu
charles aznavour car là je pense qu'ils
m'ont
dégueulasse oui je pense que sefolosha
n'avons jamais fait leurs classes et
mathieu s'embrasse sur la bouche
arrivées l'amour j'aimais beaucoup y
avaient l'amour mais il n'aimait pas
votre gueule je sais pas si vous avez
entendu là à la fin cyril dire il paraît
que c'est dégueulasse aujourd'hui c est
pourquoi il pu dire ça mais qui
d'habitude si sûr de lui enfin mon
sentiment c'est vrai cette petite
fragilité vous souvenez non mais il va
servir de clé dit ah ouais là qui n'a
plus aucun respect pour vous et ça
commence à se voir
c'est mon cas car oui le temps là
derrière pendant l'émission autant
pendant la pub à louis ii
je sais pas si l on regarde l ou bien
son petit mec pendant la pub ça vous
avez payé pendant les pubs en fait là
bloqué sur votre pub tenue d'un jour de
l'hommage
par contre la tenue
[Musique]
mais vraiment jamais elle mise à des
sorties n'ya tout ça
regard série les batteries
annie visite à jessica biel au noir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez même avoir des banlieues est
énorme elle elle se lâche m qu'il échoue
c'est sans talent ni moi ni queue ni
tête
par contre en tout cas l'humour ou
jean-luc c'est officiel c'est non n'ayez
plus peur
ah bon il a fait une heure la première
en faveur de 19 ans à ouvrir maxime
bézier meilleur 6 us à ses vaches avions
oui allez on passe au top et danses tous
ces petits moments de tpm paix qu'on
aurait dû effacer cette semaine
[Musique]
présentement sur une autre
dimanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais oui c'est fait communication
[Musique]
moi je suis raide amoureuse de vous mais
c'est platonique non mécanique
[Musique]
faux
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est que les sportifs suisses étaient
bien mais pourquoi vous fais et c'est
peut-être là très heureuse comme ça non
mais ce qui change de 2 est vrai cela se
retrouve dans votre sac et m'a parlé des
remontées gastriques
c'est roger pas la pression mathieu no 1
des malades peut-être ouais c'est non je
comprends pas ce qui génère je pense que
c'est parce que j'étais derrière ou
devant et un truc qui m'a fait peur une
renault mégane non je sais d oignon j'ai
découvert un quart d'heure après j'ai
les yeux qui pleurait ses théories mais
me des oignons des rayons pourquoi tu
rigoles et d'un seul coup tu te rends
compte que tu as des oignons mais je
sais pas c'est pourquoi j'ai un mec qui
met des oignons sous le truc ça ça ne
parle pas c'est normal pour vous
expliquer on a fait des missions au fait
où j'avais des oignons et en fait je les
avais mis dieu derrière l'ordinateur de
qui elle les voyait pas et toutes les
missions j'allais voir kelly je disais
mais franchement tu pues l'absence
réelle toute l'année mais vas-y tu
racontes
j'ai franchement tu t'es pas la vie ce
matin c'est pas grave ça arrive à tout
le monde et à bon voilà après la grille
et après jeudi et mis sous isabelle
niveau là et ça n'a pas gêné du tout
[Applaudissements]
les oignons mais lui n'a crû que c'était
moi bah oui pas forcément sans
inspiration et à côté de moi quand est
ce que vous faites une soirée toutes les
deux à coup on vient de mes très tard
très tard
alors j'aurais pu rajouter à stoke
dénoncent la réaction de jean-michel or
lors du legs de lara fabian jado venue
chanter son nouveau single papillon je
vous vous en souvenez j'adore vous allez
voir gens me va essayer de faire une
vanne rapport à cindy sanders qui avait
chanté papillon de lumière on avale et
moisie
le problème c'est que sur lara fabian
syrie est très premier degré donc moisi
ou pas faux pas de vanne du tout
regardez bien la tête de jean miche à la
fin un petit garçon qui s'est fait
gronder commun pour que la crise arrive
[Musique]
changer sa défaveur
faux
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
alors on ne touche pas lara fabian ont
eu tout faux pas jamais jamais jamais
jamais jamais d'entre eux aussi des
images de la preuve les pins perf et la
semaine il ya trois semaines
et comme ce n'est pas fait je voulais
remercier sincèrement les chroniqueurs
qui était tous content de me retrouver
la présentation
sauf peut-être un zeki
là
m
on aime aussi comme ça non non on n'aime
pas ça me fait de la peine q ma place à
chronique bonne place ça va être très
bien sûr votre sofa aller pour signer la
semaine dernière également les
téléspectateurs ont cru percevoir un une
petite tension entre isabelle et vous
non si l'on mais c'était après un oui
c'était quoi devait chanter elle devait
chanter sur du sur des français n'a pas
du tout c'était la sortie d'un magnéto
sur les épaves et honnêtement on n'a pas
compris pourquoi il y avait cette
tension 1 vous vous souvenez ou pas de
ça du tout ça m'a énormément les
barrages pas douter alors j'ai été
chercher comme ça dans l'hérault or
c'est ce qui s'était passé avant lanta
s'est passé ça vous l'avez voir isabelle
morini bosc pour la diffusion parce que
c'est vrai que isabelle a été très
touchée également sais pas
c'est dans le reportage sa direction a
tout essayé je sais me mettais trop long
ça c'est sûr les maisons de retraite tu
mets sur les choix qu il allait voir
isabelle morini-bosc sont la diffusion
parce que c'est vrai que isabelle a été
très touchée également fait pas bon vous
savez pourquoi tu allais la voie
révolutionnaire grâce à toi que j'ai mis
les oignons
c'est la vidéo n'est jamais la voir des
médecins la boucle est bouclée
ouais bon il y en a encore mais on va
arrêter là on peut le faire aller on le
fait non si l'on m'a dit que c'était on
était je me régale et après la balance
son poste alors un instant les cherry on
aura le jeune homme vous savez le jeune
homme qui a été refusée d'un monarque
oui on a et on a essayé de faire la même
chose avec en caméra cachée vous verrez
ce qui s'est passé on aura donc ce jeune
homme qui sera celle ci intervenant la
semaine il sera avec nous dans un
instant et on aura également brune
poirson
la secrétaire d'état à l'écologie qui
sera avec nous qui est exceptionnel ça
et ouais alors donné un peu plus vous
mais finalement ouais ouais
alors oui bah patrons coupables et on
commence par benjamin castaldi qui s'est
toujours pas remis de la chanson de nino
et rim k avec même s'il est un peu en
boucle sur une phrase en particulier et
je crois que valérie benaïm et au bout
de sa vie
[Musique]
moi je vous dis voilà mmdh ou encore des
potes à tf1 oubli demain ça va être une
émission de fou puisqu'on aura toute
l'équipe dallas 2 jamel debbouze gamme
adams bouder tout le monde et on parle
pas ça ne m'emballe pas bouder et walid
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mieux c'est très rare que le nouvel mois
et bien d'autres je dis la vérité il est
bien gentil série je te dis vraiment
chercher je vous dis j'ai ri il ya un
gag toutes les cinq minutes
[Musique]
et même si avec basso nico toi tes
propres en tout cas c'est ce qui m'a pas
vu le matin au réveil non non et non
hélas comme ça je l'adorent tu aurais
envie de s'en aller frangy akio
[Musique]
alors
c'est maxime gainey lui un peu le
sourire et il a dû maxime gagnant lui
attachant tout docteur fonctionne aussi
grâce à son format assez je crois quoi
kim wacken un jour jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non